I've seen that the NLR ratio is important, so I think you're talking about the neutrophil lymphocyte ratio is important, can you explain?
Did it always include that test? Well, you could configure that data if you do a CBC, that's a complete blood count, with a differential.
So a differential that measures the types of white blood cell, what's my neutrophil count, what's my lymphocyte count?
So yeah, that ratio is important because you want that balanced, right?
If you have low lymphocytes and high neutrophils, you've got to go, okay, that's not good.
Well, let's even let's say they're both within normal range, but the lymphocytes are suppressed, okay, I'll tell you right now, if you're going to do chemotherapy, your lymphocytes are going to be suppressed.
If your lymphocytes are suppressed, it's your lymphocytes subtypes, they'll never do the subtypes of the lymphocytes, or you won't get that on a CBC with differential, and I've never seen a oncologist ever run that test.
And I don't think it's necessary, but the subtypes of the lymphocytes are going to be the T cells and the natural killer cells, which are the two subtypes that kill cancer.
So those are subtypes of lymphocytes, not neutrophils. So you want is strong lymphocytes as you can.
Now, if you have excess lymphocytes and suppressed neutrophils, that's another, those are signs.
So remember, a blood test is just a sign. It's a sign of something.
So if I have low white blood cell code, that's a sign of something. Well, I'm doing chemo. Okay, well, it's a fact of the chemo then. That's what the sign is.
It's showing the effect of chemo. Let's say I have a suppressed white blood cell count, and I'm not doing chemo. I don't even have cancer.
Well, then that's a sign of something else, typically a chronic infection.
If I have elevated white blood cell count, then I look at the differential to give me further signs.
So an elevated white blood cell count is a sign of an acute infection.
And then you look at lymphocytes versus neutrophils. If the lymphocytes are high, the neutrophils are low.
I just said that was good for cancer, but that's not good when the sign is something different.
So that's a sign of a viral infection. If the neutrophils are high, the lymphocytes are suppressed. That's a sign of a bacterial infection.
Because you have elevated white blood cells and elevated neutrophils or elevated lymphocytes and suppressed neutrophils.
So blood tests are just signs of something.
But if you're doing chemotherapy, you're really looking at the total white blood cell count.
And yeah, looking at the differential, I have low white blood cell count, let's say post chemotherapy, and I have low lymphocytes post chemotherapy.
Oh no, that's not good. Well, it isn't good, but it is what it is. So you're doing things to build up the immune system.
What can I do to build up the immune system? You're already doing everything you can. There isn't any magic missing supplement that's going to boost your white blood cell count.
Now, there are some drugs that will stimulate white blood cell count because they stimulate the growth of white blood cells that people have argued that is a Taoism.
The right thing to do, no, we'll boost the white blood cell count if you, you know, able to continue to do chemotherapy.
But it's not a natural way to stimulate the immune system. You need it to grow normally.
The problem is that the chemotherapy is not going to die because it's also highly metabolic.
So, so yes, you can look at the ratio and calculate the ratio or you don't need to calculate.
And then you're just looking at that ratio through the differential.
But most people that do chemotherapy that are going to have suppressed white blood cells are also going to have suppressed lymphocytes because that's the most metabolically active line of white blood cells.
It really would affect the neutrophils so much, it would affect the monocytes, the acidophils, the vasophils that's going to really affect the lymphocytes.